[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec l'animal
d'afrique magazine dont josiane bonsoir
et virginie herz présentatrice du
magazine actuel sur france 24 dont jours
virginie
et on commence avec ce qu'il faut bien
appeler désormais le stade gates la
pagaille samedi soir au stade de france
en prélude au match liverpool real
finale de ligue des champions et qui
vire depuis un autre match france
angleterre
les deux pays se renvoyant la balle pour
ce fiasco gérald darmanin était
auditionné cet après-midi par la
commission des lois du sénat aux côtés
de sa nouvelle collègue du gouvernement
amélie oudéa castéra en charge des
sports on aurait pu rêver mieux comme
baptême du feu à l'eau ministre de
l'intérieur qui en tout cas a reconnu
des manquements de la part de certains
policiers écoutez
moi je veux dire ici que les décisions
qui ont été prises ont permis de sauver
des vies il ya eu des gestes
inappropriés disproportionnée d'un
certain nombre de la part de policiers
ou de gendarmes mobiles qui ont été
documentés je veux dire qu'il ya deux
saisines igpn en tout cas deux
signalements j'ai évidemment donné
instruction et j'ai peine de les étudier
donc le gaz lacrymogène a permis de
sauver un certain nombre de personnes de
l'écrasement il a aussi pesé côté des
grands dégâts notamment sur des enfants
j'ai comme vu comme vous voulez des
images voudrais m'en excuser très
sincèrement de cette utilisation
disproportionnée et des sanctions seront
prises je voulais communiquerait ya un
changement de ton quand même un chai
oui il ya probablement eu un moment une
intervention de l'elysée pour dire
on redescend parce que les premières
réactions étaient très gênés pas
autoritaire mais disons très assurée sur
le fait qu'il y avait aucun problème etc
puis après ce qui s'est passé comme
souvent dans ces histoires c'est qu'il
ya eu d'abord un espèce de flux d'image
qui est sorti sur les réseaux où on a pu
voir
sans avoir d' analyse structurée mais on
a pu voir ce qui se passait et
deuxièmement petit à petit
il ya les éléments qui se sont mis les
uns derrière les autres donc à un moment
on pouvait plus tenir cette ligne j'ai
raison ils ont tous tort les anglais
sont tous méchants on est tous bons et
donc je pense que personnellement il ya
sûrement eu une intervention pour dire
il faut descendre le le niveau de
2-2-2
d'importance de ce dossier pour qu'on
passe à d'autres choses des élections et
que ça sur le fond on en parlait juste
un peu avant le plateau c'est qu'on est
dans un espèce de scénario où tout à
tout l'été et ce quinté il y avait
visiblement c'est quelque chose de très
important une finale la ligue des
champions c'est beaucoup de monde ne
peut pas dire qu'on est surpris on va
dire que oui liverpool va venir au
secours qu'est ce qu'on va faire un vrai
choix oui on avait six mois et les
ruisseaux saint pétersbourg parce qu'il
faut dire que ce match devait à
l'origine se jouer à saint pétersbourg
et puis pour cause de leur nom d'ahmed
c'est que si un pays comme la france
n'est pas capable en six mois de gérer
une finale de la ligue des champions est
ce qu'il est capable de gérer dans deux
ans
des jeux olympiques est ce qu'il est
capable de gérer l'été prochain une
coupe du monde de rugby est-ce qu'on
n'est pas sur un schéma de maintien de
l'ordre de ces événements totalement
dépassés on l'a vu à saint-etienne
également le même week end avec un match
de barrage entre première league et
c'est donc tout ça est sorti d'un seul
coup et c'est ça qui est très perturbant
vous avez vu aussi maintenant qu'on
parle de la cérémonie d'ouverture des
jeux olympiques de ces espèces de design
sur la scène où on dit mais on pourra
jamais on pourra jamais sécurisé de ça
donc il ya une partie anecdotique mais à
une partie politique à une partie de pas
de chance c'est une partie dont c'est
pas organiser c'est très ennuyeux quand
même pour un pays comme la france il ya
une partie de ces la faute des anglais
mais non tout le monde c'est la faute de
tout le monde y compris à la cgt qui
trouve le moyen de coller une grève le
soir d'une finale et qui en proposent
leur propose une autre pour france
danemark d'ailleurs histoire de bien
roder le système et il ya la question de
fond est ce que ce pays est
structurellement organisé est ce que ces
forces de police sont à un certain
niveau qui permet d'organiser des
événements de cette ampleur et des
événements encore plus grand dans la
zone d'europe qui compte la plus forte
densité policière donc c'est pas un
manque de moyens humains non je pense
qu'il ya un vrai problème de da proches
de ces événements je pense que depuis
quelques années sur le football en
particulier il ya quelque chose de très
répressif parce qu'on a peur et donc on
fait mais on a vu aussi qu'il ya eu le
même débat sur les gilets jaunes on a vu
fait c'est un débat quand même qui
mérite qu'on s'y intéresse et qui est
aussi un bêta débat démocratique il faut
dire en tout cas on appuie peut-être de
ce qu'a dit alain minc le président de
la république si l'on en croit la
nouvelle porte parole du gouvernement
les via grégoire aujourd'hui est sorti
de sa réserve sur ce dossier pour
appeler à davantage de transparence oui
absolument en tout cas vous avez dit
tout à l'heure il ya les législatives
dans une dizaine de jours l'opposition
profite évidemment de ce dossier pour
tirer à boulets rouges sur gérald
darmanin et emmanuel macron de façon
plus générale marine le pen d'ailleurs
qui réclament la démission du ministre
le sénat est contrôlé par l'opposition
de droite 1 voilà et donc il ya eu cette
conférence de presse aujourd'hui qui a
duré deux heures quasiment installée et
gerald martin est arrivé avec
une explication un exposé qui a duré une
heure extrêmement détaillée avec une
évolution dans sa position au début par
exemple ils disaient nous n'avons rien
à nous reprocher le service de police
étaient bien en place d'ailleurs il
était double par rapport à la coupe à la
coupe de france est finalement à la fin
de son exposé disait bon peut-être qu'il
faut quand même revoir ce dispositif
le sécrétaire pour les événements
exceptionnels donc avait une évolution
ce qui est officiellement le président
de la république
de réclame la transparence la lumière
pour que ça ne se reproduise plus
justement en vue de ces événements à
venir plus de réactivité en coulisses
quand même le canard enchaîné rapporte
qu'il a été extrêmement en colère qui ne
trouvait que le spectacle était
pitoyable honteux et indigne de la
france pour le moment il maintient
officiellement son soutien au ministre
de l'intérieur va voir comment ça va se
développer et notamment au niveau
diplomatique parce que les tensions
persistent et les tensions persistent
avec l'amp parce que sur les faits
eux-mêmes gérald darmanin l'assurent il
y avait 110 mille supporters présents
autour du stade de france alors que
seuls 75 mille billets avaient été
vendus autrement dit des supporteurs de
liverpool présents en nombre et qui
n'auraient rien à faire là ou en tout
cas qui se trouve en position possession
de faux billets écouter les stadiers du
stade de france ont un stylo chimique
qui permet de raturer pourvoir selon la
couleur est ce que ce billet vrai ou
est-ce que ce biais faut et il s'est
trouvé que dans ce premier prêt filtrage
que nous on a appliqué que la stade de
france pardon à appliquer partout sur
toutes les entrées du stade de france
seule l'entrée du rer d qui amenait le
plus évidemment de supporters anglais
vers les virages britanniques ont posé
des problèmes et d'après les équipes de
la fédération française de football et
du stade de france plus de 50 % des
billets entre 57 et 70% selon les
entrées étaient faut voir c'est énorme
c'est énorme c'est des dizaines de
milliers de faux billets ça vous semble
plausible yade aussi un problème gérald
darmanin aujourd'hui
il ya un problème pour le miz
l'intérieur d'être exposés à cette
situation et de ne pas avoir de réponses
très précises et de réponse fluctuante
après les chiffres des faux billets on
est passé de 3000 à 50000 de cinquante
mille à deux mille cinq cents de 8000 à
40 milles donc là je tends qui aura pas
une enquête indépendante pour nous
expliquer qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
termes de billetterie
alors il ya cette information judiciaire
quai aux fruits et puis je pense que le
il va ya voir la suite avec des plaintes
etc mais il ya quand même un point très
particulier qui fait que les anglais
auraient exigé des billets papier on
sait pas très bien pourquoi les
espagnols avaient leur billet comme mon
nom de la coutume est ce qu'il faut pas
proscrire les billets papier alors il
faut peut-être proscrire les billets
papier mais je ne vois pas sauf si on
imprime nous débit sauf si nous on
produit facile le stade de france où
l'uefa où je sais pas qui fait ses
billets si on fait des billets
suffisamment nul qui suffit de les
photocopier parce que pour faire
quarante mille faux billets en en
quelques semaines il faut quand même y
aller quoi et qu'ils aient l'air
relativement crédible parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le stylo le hakama il ya quand
même un filtre qui boit loin à pied donc
moi j'ai un peu de mal à croire à cette
théorie des 40000 sauf si on a fabriqué
des billets réel mais tel de d'une telle
qualité faiblarde qu'ils étaient faciles
à juste faire un pds il attend juste
pour consommer l'insistance même des
supporters anglais à vouloir absolument
s'accrocher aux billets papier présenté
ici en france comme le signe justement
d'une volonté de les falsifier oui alors
la dernière version quand même du
ministre de l'intérieur c'est de dire
c'est pas quarante mille faux billets
mais quarante mille personnes
supplémentaires dont certains n'avaient
pas de billets et d'autres avaient des
faux billets qui a eu des problèmes
informatiques au moment du contrôle des
billets etc ce qui est clair c'est qu'il
ya deux versions complètement opposé à
liverpool on est on est vent debout
contre contre la france le président du
club le directeur exécutif du club a
annoncé que le club avait reçues lui
cinq mille plaintes sur sa plate forme
il vient d'annoncer aussi qu' il a lancé
un soutien psychologique aux supporters
qui ont été traumatisés par ces
événements lui même a été absolument
horrifié il réclame des excuses or les
excuses en a pas véritablement eu les
excuses pour lui il ya eu deux excuses à
un moment donné la ministre des sports a
répondu que liverpool était un grand
club et qu'elle s'excusait auprès de
ceux qui n'avaient pas pu les supporters
de liverpool qui n'avait pas pu assister
au match c'est-à-dire 2700 personnes
quant à au ministre de l'intérieur lui
il a présenté ses excuses aux familles
qui avait été gazé mais c'est tout pour
le reste c'était juste des regrets qui
ont été exprimées un fonds de 2 2 n
poste brixi diable non je pense qu'il ya
une perception du hooligans anglais kibo
qui est pas dénuée d'historicité je veux
dire on se rappelle de ce que ça a été
de ce que ce qu'ont été les hooligans on
se rappelle qu'il ya eu des drames en
angleterre majeur riche et fils qui
impliquait déjà à l'époque d'ailleurs le
club de liverpool a donc on peut
comprendre qu'ils aient une certaine
j'allais dire appréhension quand
liverpool débarque à paris mais excusez
moi encore une fois ce qui s'est passé à
saint-etienne c'est pas le dire c'est
pas propre aux anglais et encore une
fois on n'est pas dans un match j'ai vu
la régionale envahi par les supporters
le début la référence au couple à la
coupe de france c'est pas la coupe de
france et une finale de la ligue des
champions avec le real de madrid le
liverpool ces deux très grands clubs
c'est clair qu'il va y avoir deux cent
mille personnes qui vont venir à paris
c'est clair que tout ça va être
compliqué si votre stratégie les
statiques et on voit les images c'est ça
qui est terrible on voit ces bus de
police qui bloquent les accès en espèces
dans tu as maintenant on voit des
policiers ou des crs qui utilisent des
bombes lacrymo dans le visage des gens
donc tout ça c'est là et c'est ça qui
pose problème c'est ce jour des
initiatives en com comme ceux que posent
problème une partie de la réaction de la
classe politique française quand
j'entends un présentateur connu le dire
c'est parce que benzema a été au real de
madrid ça a attiré toute la racaille jeu
on est dans quel pays on oui parce que
leur voile il faut lire là la droite
pour parler franchement et pour ceux qui
ne suivent fils étrangers accusent le
gouvernement de terre des faits de
violence qui serait
d'habitants de saint verny ont des
environs d'uzès france au palais terre
parce qu'il ya des témoignages des
anglais qui ont été dépouillés des
ingénieurs ont été dépouillés il ya même
des témoignages d'agressions sexuelle il
ya des images qui ont été diffusées sur
les réseaux où on voit les gamins passer
au-dessus excusez moi je sais pas
comment c'est quoi ces barrières passe
au dessus des barrières en dans le
stalles tout ça on le sait on sait que
ce stade aussi
est implantée dans une zone difficile
que ces accès sont très compliquées il a
été fait pour la coupe du monde 98 ces
accès sont très complexes il faut aussi
voir le côté social de l'événement
seront sur les réseaux on parlait de
billets à 2000 euros à 3000 euros on est
implanté dans une ville un quartier
populaire d une des villes les plus
pauvres de france une des villes les
plus difficiles de france et on voit
très bien que c'est une partie de ces
gamins là il ya une provoc absolue
d'aller se filmer à l'intérieur du stade
en disant oui moi j'ai payé rien du tout
j'ai escaladé bande de riches bande de
bourges a donc tout est là c'est ce
qu'on disait c'est la perfect storm mais
puisqu'il ya eu perfect storm et qu'elle
va revenir avec la coupe du monde de
rugby et qu'il y aura les jeux
olympiques dans deux ans etc parlons-en
en dehors du politiquement certes c'est
intéressant mais parlons-en sur le fond
on va en venir peut-être à l'image du
jour à présent alors on est loin du foot
c'est shanghai ces 25 millions
d'habitants qui avant de retourner dans
les stades en tout cas ressort enfin de
leur logement où ils sont restés
confinés pendant deux mois et coûté la
vie ce maire de la ville
l'épidémie a été efficacement maîtriser
toute la ville entrera dans la troisième
phase c'est à dire l'étape de la reprise
complète de la production et de la
restauration de l'ordre de vie dans
toute la ville
virginie on a tous souffert quand même
pour les chinois pendant deux mois pour
voir un ce qu'ils avaient enduré en tout
cas les habitants de la ville de
shanghai ça a marqué une rupture réelle
entre la population et le pouvoir
chinois
et sa stratégie zéro qu'ovide alors réel
c'est difficile à mesurer on est quand
même en chine dans un pays qui à
contrôler la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'expression de façon générale
ce qu'on peut rappeler c'est que il ya
eu des manifestations de mécontentement
assez marquant inédite de la part
d'étudiants notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux de façon un petit peu caché ce
qu'il ya c'est que jusqu'à présent il y
avait un consensus en chine qui était
que le parti communiste s'occupe de la
prospérité économique et en échange la
population le laisse s'occuper de tout
ce qui est affaires intérieures et
politique là il ya aussi une remise en
cause du système économique donc il peut
y avoir effectivement remise en cause
aussi du système politique et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il semblerait que
les recherches sur les demandes
d'immigration sur l'expatriation de
chine sur internet à ses demandes
ont exposé en tout cas les recherches
ont exposé au point que les autorités
chinoises ont réagi et ont mis en place
un système de migration street c'est à
dire que l interdisent tout simplement
les sorties non essentielles du pays
sous prétexte que vous allez vous
contaminer ailleurs dans le monde mais
en réalité c'est pour effectivement
peut-être aussi contrôler des sorties
massives chinois qui experts dans la
manière de manier le bâton et le bâton
ziad ces images bon évidemment elles
sont lointaines mais ici même en france
on voit m est reproché fort d'ailleurs
on voit les cas de candide repartir à la
hausse depuis une semaine la photo sous
variant omicron ados micro non c'est pas
trop c'est que ces fameux beac a b à 4
mg et à 5 c ca sont repartis à partir
d'afrique du sud sont déjà aux états
unis sont déjà au portugal donc on sait
depuis le début de cette épidémie qui
sait qu'une question de semaines pour
que ça vienne nous voir après par
rapport à la chine c'est qu'on a une
natte une approche comme vous le savez
complètement différente c'est les
chinois c'est que vous et rocco vide et
nous si vivre avec le côté 0 masque
aujourd'hui c'est zéro masque clouté
ouvert et je pense que même s'il ya une
remontée des cas dans la plupart des
pays européens dans leur aux amériques
en tous les cas le problème c'est pas
forcément la remontée des casses et les
hospitalisations et les décès s'il ya
une remontée en flèche de supputations
et des décès ou pas le deuxième problème
qu'on ne connaît pas très bien c'est
l'immunité acquise les études semblent
montrer que sur les personnes âgées à
comorbidités cette immunité s'est
affaibli et donc il est possible que ces
personnes âgées soient de nouveau enfin
les plus âgés d'entre nous soit de
nouveau la première cible du virus si ça
devait rebondir pendant l'été ou au
début de l'automne mais en gros la
pandémie n'est pas fini c'est juste que
on a appris à vivre avec les chinois et
pas seulement les chinois y en a
d'autres essayent de vivre avec 100 100
chacun paye le prix est malheureusement
le virus lui il est toujours là et on
verra si on peut continuer à vivre avec
le mieux possible du moins cet été un
merci beaucoup à l'automne surtout à
l'automne
merci ziade merci et un génie c'était on
va plus loin on se retrouve nous dans
moins de cinq minutes pour un nouveau
journal reste avec nous